today on the Matt Walsh show citizens in
Michigan are standing up to the tyranny
from their power-drunk governor is this
the start of a trend are we gonna see
more and more of this around the country
I really hope so we'll talk about that
also 5 headlines including CNN anchor
Chris Cuomo making some interesting
admissions about his job that I sort of
appreciate that what he had to say so
we'll discuss that and in our daily
cancellation the executive editor of the
New York Times offers an absolutely
ridiculous justification for why the
paper has treated the allegations
against Joe Biden the sexual assault
allegations against Biden so differently
from how it treated the allegations
against Kavanaugh of course we know the
real reason why why there is this
disparity but he came up with his own
excuse and it's so bad that
unfortunately it pains me to do it but I
have to cancel him for it so all that on
the way but first I want to begin real
quick with with this I just something I
have to say at the top you know I sent
out this tweet over the weekend where I
would take a look at it here where I
criticized those videos that you see all
over tick-tock now of nurses doing these
choreographed dance routines at
hospitals around the country and as you
can see there I said we were told we had
to willingly plunge ourselves into a
great depression because hospitals are
being overwhelmed meanwhile tick tock is
full of videos of hospital staff
performing choreographed dance routines
what a joke this whole thing and Sherri
ating that's why I said okay
the point being well I think the point
is pretty straightforward I think my
point there is it's pretty obvious
they're millions people have lost their
jobs because we're told about
overwhelmed overrun hospitals and
imagine being one of those people maybe
in line at a food bank and you go and
you check your phone and you see another
video of nurses literally dancing in the
hallways of empty hospitals okay that
might make you a little bit upset and
that was my point now the response to
this tweet that I sent has been
extraordinary extraordinarily bad for
the most part people have been very
upset I've been getting criticized very
harshly for it because I have dared to
criticize the saint the sainted nurses
which you know you're just not allowed
to do that you can't you can't criticize
them for anything they do right now and
because apparently I am anti fun and
anti joy I am again
people having any sort of fun at all
because I'm against nurses doing
choreographed dance routines and
recording it and putting it online in
the middle of a pandemic and a shutdown
this cost millions of people their jobs
because I'm against that
it means I'm against fun in general
which is true of course I am against fun
as you as you know I've been informed
that my tweet is insensitive cruel
judgmental on and on and on and people
have said I need to apologize
I need to apologize profusely take it
down
delete it so after all this criticism
I've had time to reflect it I just want
to say I need to say I'm not sorry about
anything that I said at all and if
you're offended I'm not sorry that
you're offended in fact I don't care
about your feelings
I just don't it has no sway or pull with
me whatsoever make some a difference so
I just don't care even if I was wrong I
still wouldn't apologize on principle
I'm not going to apologize when you've
got a gang of whiny idiots demanding one
even in that case I could be a hundred
percent wrong and I still wouldn't but
in this case I'm not wrong I'm a hundred
percent right and if you disagree with
my point here then you're wrong and
again I don't apologize if I could do it
all over again I would do the exact same
thing and a million more emails will not
make me change my opinion because and
this is the point I really want to drive
home when you get mad and you scream at
me and you tell me I'm wrong and that I
need to stop having the opinion that I
have and I need to stop expressing the
opinion that I've expressed all that
does is make me even more sure of my
opinion and more likely to say it even
louder so again not sorry at all and I
just want to clarify that and it's good
to get you know it's good to get that
off off your chest a little bit of
conflict resolution there okay now let's
let's check out some positive news I
consider this to be positive and in fact
before we do that speaking of positive
news I want to check in with our good
for
over at Rock Auto you know if you if
you're having trouble right now with
your car especially with all the
different you know depending on where
you live with all the different policies
and laws I mean where are you allowed to
go can you even go do you want to go to
a auto parts store it's just better to
cut all that out and you could just pick
up your phone or go into the computer
and go to rockauto.com it's much easier
than walking into a store and someone
demanding quick answers to questions
that you might not have an answer to and
then they're just gonna order the part
online anyway the rockauto.com catalog
is unique very easy to navigate has
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts tail lamps motor oil
everything you need and it's a family
business even though this is an online
business they've been doing it for a
long time 20 years but it's also a
family business which you know it's
important to me so that's that's that's
also good Rock auto comm always offers
the lowest prices best selection just
everything you can want go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck right walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you all
right now let's check out some as I said
some other other positive news I
consider this to be positive some
citizens are rising up and taking action
the Michigan codes conservative
coalition and the Michigan freedom fund
two organizations have organized the
protest at the State Capitol in Michigan
thousands of people are expected to show
up descending on the city in their cars
they're gonna stay in their cars and I
can have the cars but they're gonna be
in their cars it's kind of like a March
except in their cars and they're gonna
circle the Capitol building and there's
gonna be gridlock there's gonna be
traffic that's the idea that to make a
statement against governor Gretchen
Whitmer and some of the the the measures
that she has adopted ostensibly
supposedly to fight the coronavirus
epidemic but really it's just about her
flexing her muscle and her power and
that's what this is all about so they're
gonna be standing up against that now
Emperor Whitmer has like so many other
many emperors around the country taking
advantage of the crisis of course to
grab power that she is not entitled to
and to boost her
national profile which is a big thing
for her obviously she's a petty
narcissistic tyrant she's drunk on Fame
and power she's the kind of politician
who and there are a lot of these in
government the kind of politician who
would have been dangerous with the power
given to her like if she was an
assistant manager at a pizza place she
would have been dangerous with that
amount of power over a few people you
know over like three teenagers working
with for her and at a pizza place she
would've been dangerous with that power
but you make her governor and you put
her into the middle of an emergency
situation like this and she goes
literally insane with power
she becomes basically like this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that's really governors all across
the country have become like Jafar after
he gets after he gets the genies lamp at
the end of Aladdin and wishes to become
the most powerful genie in the world I
could have gone with maybe the Golem and
the ring analogy would have worked too
but I decided to go with the more
millennial reference which by the way
the one problem I have with that with
that movie is at the end you know Jafar
becomes the most powerful genie and then
it turns out that he gets tricked
because now he's a slave as a genie and
then Aladdin Aladdin puts him back in
the lamp and he's you know stuck in the
lamp now and then the good genie Robin
Williams the Robin Williams genie
he takes the lamp with the evil genie
and he just Chuck's it into the desert
and I'm thinking that is not probably
the safest disposal method for evil
genies you're just throwing it into the
desert
it was Aladdin found the thing in a
desert someone's just gonna find it and
we're gonna go through all this again so
why not I mean put it at the bottom of
the ocean at least or burn it anyway so
there's gonna be a protest and that's
great and this is exactly what we need
to happen just to give you an idea of
why Emperor Whitmer is being protested
she instituted a stay at home order back
several weeks ago like they have in many
states now but which as we talked
yesterday is is not a quarantine okay
this is these are we call them stayed
home orders but really it's effectively
house arrest
she has placed the entire state under
house arrest which she also does not
have the authority to do but no one's
worried about that anymore but this past
week she made it even stricter and now
by decree of the emperor residents are
banned from for example traveling
between their own residences okay so if
you happen to own two houses in Michigan
you cannot go from one house to the
other
why now reason there's not any reason
for that it's it's there's if you live
in a house and you get out of your house
and you you cross your yard into your
driveway you get in your car and then
you drive to your second house and you
get out of the car and you go there's
really no point in between that whole
process where you're likely to contract
spread the virus so there's no reason to
ban that except for the fact that
Emperor Whitmer Ken so she does also
let's see there's a bunch of other stuff
in this in this new order really mo read
now from the text of the Emperor's order
it says subject to the exceptions in
section 7 of this order bla bla bla all
individuals currently living in within
the state of Michigan are ordered to
stay at home or at their place of
residence subject to the same exceptions
all public and private gatherings of any
number of people occurring among persons
not part of a single household are
prohibited okay private gatherings of
any number of people are prohibited well
what does that mean
it means you are barred in Michigan from
welcoming your own family members into
your home if you have a brother who
lives across town he's not allowed to
enter your house this is an order from
the Emperor of Michigan saying your
brother cannot come to your house or
your uncle or a grandmother or whoever
else Emperor Whitmer has assumed the
power to tell residents that they cannot
have their own families in their homes
this is something I would call this
dictatorial but this is this is
trailblazing as a dictator really
because as far as I know now I'm not
really familiar totally with the
legislation in a place like North Korea
but as far as I know even Kim jong-un
has not thought of this
he hasn't even thought of telling the
peasants of North Korea that they can't
have their own families over for dinner
so this is she's blazing a new trail the
the supreme leader of North Korea is
looking at the supreme leader of
Michigan and thinking wow that's a good
eye I should have thought that these are
some good ideas he's like taking notes
while he reads these executive orders
now on top of that she's also as has
happened in many other states she has
told the so-called essential retailers
they're allowed to sell and what they're
not allowed to sell and what we'll get
in in the the exceptions and the things
that are not accepted are pretty absurd
we'll get to that just a second before
we do I want to check in with our good
friends over at LifeLock you know it's
it's good to be prepared for every
potential eventualities
always prepared for everything you know
I'm not one of those people I am NOT a
very well prepared I wasn't a very good
Boy Scout in terms of being prepared but
I know people are I wish that I was and
that's where LifeLock comes in there are
some people you know seem like they're
prepared for anything and if you have a
cut you know they're gonna have a
bandage or a band-aid if you need a
battery they've got multiple sizes on it
we I don't have that I've got what I
need a battery I'm we're always
harvesting it from a remote and you know
you're stitching together batteries from
other things that have batteries now so
I'm not one of those people either but
when it comes to something like identity
theft I think that's where we all need
to be prepared this is something that's
happening more and more these days
breaches are happening and with your
breached information like your name
social security number and more
criminals can commit identity theft and
that's why life lock sees more threats
like someone taking out a payday loan in
your name and they can alert you to two
possible suspicious activity they're
gonna be they're gonna be better
equipped to find those threats that you
are just yourself and hey if something
does happen and god forbid you have your
identity stolen then they've got
identity theft restoration specialist or
just a phone call away and they can take
care of it for you no one can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions all the time but with
breaches on the rise doesn't it make
sense to be as prepared as you possibly
can be joined life lock today and save
up to 25% off your first year go to life
lock calm slash Walsh that's life lock
calm slash walls to save 25% off okay
also the deed the emperor decrees that
the following sections of all stores for
all the essential stores that are still
allowed to be open according to her
decree are to be cordoned off that is a
carpeting or flooring can sell carpeting
for furniture garden centers and plant
nurseries and paint those are the things
she's decided if you go and try to buy
one of those you might get coronavirus
so you can't you can't buy that garden
centers and plant nurseries so you can't
grow your own vegetables because of
coronavirus now I would think that now
is in is especially a good time to have
your own garden and grow your own
vegetables because it provides you with
fresh produce and all the natural
vitamins that come with that makes you
healthy and you don't have to go to the
store as much because you can grow it in
your own garden I would think this is a
perfect time for that if anything the
government should be encouraging people
to go and buy seeds and start their own
gardens but know it's gone the other way
she says you can't you can't do that
someone I was talking about this and
someone told me this morning on Twitter
defending the governor's order the
emperor sorry rather user appropriate
title saying that no no no it's it's not
that you can't buy seeds and plants it's
just that you can't buy it at a big-box
retailer so if you're at Walmart or
Target or something you can't go to
their garden center because those are
shut down but you can go to a separate
place and buy seeds and vegetables and
plants and stuff now I'm not sure if
that's true or not okay I don't I don't
know exactly in Michigan are it you know
there are actual garden stores are those
places allowed to be open I don't know
but the fact that this person thinks
that that's a defense see that would
make it even more arbitrary and
ridiculous because then what they're
telling you is if you're already at
let's say Walmart buying groceries and
you want some seeds to start a garden
you can't just walk across the aisle and
grab some which would be the easiest and
quickest and safest thing instead you
have to get in your car and go to a
separate place across town instead of
just walking across the store so if
that's how it's working that doesn't
make it better that makes it ten times
worse because that's now it's even more
arbitrary and it's counterproductive
because you're creating more travel
that's unnecessary by the way the
emperor has also said apparently that
novelty t-shirt printers are essential
businesses it would seem because she
took the time during this emergency to
appear on Comedy Central wearing a
custom
she made for herself or she had made for
herself you could see that right here
and it says that woman from Michigan and
that's a reference to I guess Trump
referred to her as that woman in
Michigan or a woman from Michigan or
something and so she had a you know she
had a custom t-shirt does that make
sense so you can't buy seeds but you can
make a custom t-shirt that's and that's
that's essential not doesn't make sense
but she's in power you peasants come and
it's just as simple as that
you can buy lottery tickets too by the
way in Michigan you can go to the gas
station and buy lottery tickets you can
buy scratch offs whatever you want can't
buy furniture can't buy paint can't buy
seeds you could buy lottery tickets does
that make sense
once again it doesn't but it doesn't
matter because what she says goes this
is about a petty ridiculous person who
has been given the opportunity to live
out her fantasy as essentially a
political dominatrix and that's what's
happening here
you know this whole experience 'men
happening I've been thinking a lot about
speaking before of managers at pizza
places the reason I use that example I
was thinking of a manager I had when I
worked as a pizza chef as a teenager and
I was a chef okay I could I could do
things like I could do the thing where
you spin the dough in the air that was
pretty good so that's that's chef stuff
I wasn't just a guy working at a pizza
place but my manager at that job was
just an absolute tyrant he had minimal
just a minimal amount of control over
the high schoolers who worked for him
during his shift and he exploited it to
the fullest extent so if that power was
in like a sponge he was wringing that
sponge out and just getting every last
drop and morsel he could of power out of
that thing right and we've all had
bosses like this we've had teachers like
this there are people in every
profession in every line of work we've
encountered customer service
representatives like this I mean if
you've ever called you've had to call
someplace at one 800-number and deal
with someone at a call center
and we've all had an experience where
the person you're talking to is they
have a a minimal amount of control this
is just somebody working at a call
center they have very little power but
right now in this moment because you
need something from them and they have
the thing you need even if it's just
something like information or you need
them to pass you along to somebody else
who has the information you need they're
going to exploit that power as much as
possible just because they can and
they're gonna be difficult and they're
gonna try to make your life miserable
because they're miserable so we've all
encountered people like this now then we
have to think you know who generally are
the sorts of people who even want to be
politicians who want to have this kind
of power and control well it's exactly
like it's exactly these sorts of people
the tyrannical boss at a pizza place or
that jerkwad at the call center I mean
these these narcissists who are
miserable people and want to control
others that that doesn't have to be your
motivation for wanting to become a
politician it's possible in theory that
you could be motivated by a desire for
public service and I'm willing to
believe that there might be of all the
politicians in America
there might right now be maybe like
three or four of them who were motivated
by a desire for public service but the
vast majority of them are just the petty
narcissists and that's why they became
politicians and now they're in a
position where they have been giving
given basically unlimited power over
large numbers of people and they're
going to exploit it to the fullest
extent and that's exactly why they
shouldn't be given that power to begin
with all right let's go to news
headlines number one here's a report
from it's called spectrum News New York
and I thought this was an interesting
report watch this Delta Airlines is
temporarily changing the way passengers
board its planes travelers whose seats
are in the last row will board first and
then the process will make its way row
by row to the front with those
passengers boarding last
passengers will have to wait for their
row number to be called this change is
so that people will interact less while
getting to their seats customers in
first our business class can still board
whenever they want
they are being encouraged to wait for
their row to be called and there will
still be pre-boarding processes for
those who need extra time or assistance
Delta says the changes will stay in
place until May 31st first of all what's
up with the people boarding the plane in
that package you watch there you see
they were all smiling as they got on the
plane nobody looks like that when
they're boarding a plane
everyone is just gloomy and miserable
especially on a Delta flight of all
things but more to the point why did it
take a pandemic for Airlines to adopt a
sane boarding procedure obviously that
this is one of the things that has
perplexed airline passengers like myself
for years why why do you start by
boarding the people in the front of the
plane and then you have it just it takes
a mix that it makes the whole procedure
five times as long as it needs to be so
you start people in the back and then
you fill in from there and I guess part
of the reason they changed it is because
they want to give the people who are in
first class and the you know people in
comfort the comfort section so they get
like two inches more of legroom that
everybody else they want to give them
the privilege and honor of boarding the
plane first but I never understood that
either because on the on the rare
occasion where someone's been paying for
my flight and I get the fly first-class
because I've never paid for it myself I
don't I don't really consider it a great
honor to board the flight first because
then you're just you're just sitting on
the plane longer than everybody else why
is that so exciting so that's at least
this is one good thing that will come of
the whole pandemic is that airlines will
start boarding in a reasonable way
number two speaking of tyranny reading
now in a report from Amanda presto
Giacomo and the Daily wire it says after
fighting a grueling seven year legal
battle battle for respectfully declining
to create a cake for same-sex wedding
openly Christian Baker Jack Phillips
landed a 72 ruling in his favorite
Supreme Court the win was not enough
however the same call
agency that went after Phillips over the
same-sex wedding cake then sued the cake
artist for refusing to create a gender
transition celebration and that was the
so that he was he was first sued by the
gay couple of one of the gay wedding
cake that goes the Supreme Court and
then you've got this transgender person
who comes in and wants a gender
transition cake after all that's over
and he he basically won in the spring he
all but achieved a victory in the
Supreme Court after that happens then
you've got this person autumn scar Deena
who comes in for a gender transition
cake in an in an obvious attempt to just
entrap Jack Phillips and find an excuse
to sue he gets the excuse to sue and now
the latest is that there's a second
lawsuit this is going back to court
again and from the same person
autumns Gardena and it just it never
ends Jack Phillips you know he has been
this all started when did this start
this started I think in 2012 I believe
2013 I mean around it it's been it's
been many many years and it all just
started with Jack Phillips not even
refusing to make a cake for a gay couple
that's not what happened you know he
just he didn't want to make a custom
cake for a gay wedding he was willing to
sell the gay couple any pastry or
dessert they wanted in the entire so
they could have whatever they want it's
just I don't want to make a custom cake
specifically for a gay wedding all
starts with that and here we are six
seven years later and it still has not
ended number three a team of researchers
published a paper in the journal n
systems and in their paper they say that
two of the best things we can do to
fight the corona virus according to them
is one get fresh air to get lots of Sun
now it's not known to what extent
sunlight kills the virus but we do know
in general that sunlight is a great
disinfectant when it comes to germs and
viruses and so on plus lots of air
circulation obviously is going to reduce
your risk of contracting a virus when if
somebody coughs or something a few feet
from you
and you're inside and you've got all
that stale still recirculated air
there's a much greater likelihood you're
gonna get infected than if you're
outside and there's there's tons of
fresh air and the air is circulating and
moving and everything and there's wind
and a breeze obviously there's gonna be
less of a chance of you getting affected
now I bring that up because what have
many states and localities done in many
places they've shut down parks they've
banned outdoor recreation they're
arresting people who go to the beach and
it sounds like to me
speaking of beaches it's been
particularly it seems like one of the
best possible places you could be right
now is on a beach you've got lots of
fresh air you've got lots of heat lots
of sunlight lots of space there's
probably no better place to be for
avoiding a virus but instead what have
many places done they've shut down the
beaches and said no go to your home
where there's a much greater chance of
circulating and spreading and
contracting the virus makes a lot of
sense finally Chris Cuomo CNN anchor was
on Sirius Sirius XM radio and he had
quite a lot to say about his job and and
media in general take a listen
I don't want to spend my time doing
things that I don't think that are
valuable enough to me personally like
what well I don't like what I do
professionally I've decided I like doing
this show I like talking to you guys but
I don't value indulging irrationality
hyper-partisanship
I don't think it's worth my time and I
don't want some Jack loser fat tire
biker to be able to pull over and get in
my face and in my space and talk
[ __ ]
to me I don't want to hear it and just
like you would right you you don't
tolerate that right some cat just
basically pulls up in the driveway next
to yours
starts getting your face about stuff how
how is that gonna go how's that gonna go
right that matters to me more than
making millions of dollars a year that
matters to me more why because I've
saved my money some honesty there which
I respect it also it seems like one of
the reasons he doesn't like his job and
doesn't want his job anymore is that he
wants to be able to yell at or punch or
insult someone who insults him that the
fact that he's not able to do that
because he's a public figure upsets him
and he would be willing to give up his
multi-million dollar a year job just so
he can just so he can have the ability
to insult people who insult him I
respect that personally I really do
so let's there's not a lot of kids I
can't often say that about CNN anchors
but that at least I can respect let's go
to your daily cancellation well I had to
let the New York Times off the hook
yesterday because I had to cancel our
chickens instead which if you didn't
watch the show yesterday we'll just
leave it there no context but today
we're gonna circle back and cancel them
you remember the the New York Times
published a piece over the weekend which
went to absurd lengths to essentially
absolve Joe Biden of the sexual assault
charge made against him by Tara Reid
this after first of all taking many days
and/or weeks really to even acknowledge
the story in the first place and then
meanwhile the times in the past has
jumped on sexual assault claims made
against other people and reported them
right away uncritically and it just so
happens coincidentally they usually do
that when the person who is being
accused is a Republican I'm sure it's
just a coincidence well Dean back back
wet executive editor of The Times was
being interviewed in The Times by The
Times for some reason about all of this
and that was published yesterday I want
to read just one of these exchanges to
you so a question I've been looking at
The Times's coverage of Justice Brett
Cavanagh I want to focus particularly on
the Julie sweat NIC allegation she was
the one who was represented by Michael
avenatti and who suggested that Kavanagh
had been involved in frat house rapes
and then appeared to walk back elements
of our allegations
The Times wrote that that's the Times
wrote that story the same day she made
the allegation noting that quote none of
miss sweatin exclaims could be
independently corroborated why was Kevin
all treated differently that's the
question we get to the answer in a
second but remember it took them many
days to even acknowledge this claim this
allegation against Joe Biden and then
when they do they essentially exonerate
him but let's remember the Julie sweat
now now we remember Christine Ford that
allegation which there was no evidence
for she didn't even remember most of the
details no witnesses nobody corroborated
anything so that was bad enough
Julie sweat mix she was the one who
claimed not just that Cavanaugh was
involved in rapes at frat houses she
claimed that he was essentially the
ringleader of a of a of a group of gang
rapists who were known to show up at
parties and rape women they were just as
like according to her everybody knew
this and yet according to her women
would still go to these parties with
these gang rapists the story was
completely ridiculous it's not just that
there was no evidence for it instead it
was a on its face absurd story and the
New York Times published it the same day
that it was made okay now here's the
answer that Dean Beck w'ite gives he
says Cavanaugh was already in a public
forum in a large way Cavanaugh status as
a Supreme Court justice was in question
because of a serious of a very serious
allegation and when I say in a public
way I don't mean in the public way of
terror reads if you ask the average
person in America they didn't know about
the Tara Reid case so I thought in that
case if the New York Times was going to
introduce this to readers we needed to
introduce it with some reporting and
perspective Cavanaugh was in a very
different situation it was a live
ongoing story that had become the
biggest political story in the country
it was just a different news judgment
moment oh my gosh
I look in fairness to Dean back wet
there's no good answer to give because
of course the real answer is they're a
bunch of partisan hacks so that's the
real answer and I would respect the hell
out of him actually if you just come out
and said that I wish that had been his
answer should have just been and I would
have respected it if he had said listen
you guys know what's up here
okay we're partisan hacks they give
Biden's the Democrats different rules
okay I mean what you think we care about
about sexual assault come on
but no he he's not gonna say that and so
if he's not gonna go with the truth
there really is no good answer to give
but even without a good answer or excuse
he could have given it a little bit more
effort Cavanaugh was in a public forum
yes he was but I don't know I don't you
think that that a presidential campaign
is a public forum that the former vice
president running for president now the
presumptive nominee I you know I don't
know I would call that a public forum
too not just a public forum but a public
forum in a large way in fact I would
argue that a presidential candidate for
a major party has a much bigger public
forum than someone who's been appointed
as a Supreme Court justice and then he
says so that that excuse doesn't wash at
all and then he says if you ask the
average person in America they don't
know about the Tara Reid case yeah
why don't they know about it Dean
because people like you aren't telling
them they don't know about it because
you are going out of your way to bury
the story so the media goes out of its
way to bury the story and then uses as
justification for burying it the fact
that it was buried well we had to bury
it I mean it's been buried what are we
supposed to do it's buried we buried it
we had to bury it because we buried it
amazing
really amazing okay let's go finally two
emails Matt you can always email show by
becoming a daily wire member and you can
access the mailbag that way this is from
Damon says love your show while I see
how people might get the wrong
impression from the nurses post into
dancing videos they are still wrong
impressions you saying that they are
doing this while people are dying is a
misrepresentation you saying they must
have plenty of time on their hands is a
misrepresentation you claiming that is
especially bad during this time is a
misrepresentation of how things work in
a hospital being a nurse myself I think
you shouldn't disparage them without
actually understanding how things work
on a hospital floor just my opinion
thanks for having a great show though
well you called all misrepresentations
but then you don't explain so I don't
know how to respond to this exactly
first of all there are two things we
know here people are dying okay the
virus is a very real thing I never said
it was a hoax it's a very real thing
it's a very serious thing my point has
simply been the way the government is
responding to the to the virus is is
tyrannical counterproductive arbitrary
wrong etc etc chatter there are better
ways of responding so people are dying
it's not a misrepresentation that is
actually happening and the way I look at
it these dancing videos of nurses there
there are two possibilities right either
these videos are being in these these
dancers are being choreographed in
hospitals where people are dying of the
corona virus or not in either case it's
not good because if people are dying of
a pandemic in your hospital and you're
downstairs choreographing a dance
routine and then posting it online I
would say that's not a very appropriate
response and that's just not an
appropriate time by the way the media
they're the ones who have compared this
to 911 and I guess now they would say
that the this is whatever - ten times
worse than 911 or something by the by
the death toll so they're the ones who
made this cut this this this comparison
there are also the ones who have
defended these videos well so if that
comparison war
then wouldn't this be like a 911 first
responder doing a choreographed dance
routine at ground zero you know the week
after 911 I mean it's not my comparison
that's the media's comparison so by that
logic it's the same sort of thing would
anyone deny that that would be wildly
inappropriate and it's not that we're
saying that 911 first responders can't
have any fun or can't enjoy their lives
or have to be solemn and gloomy all the
time but I'm not even saying they can't
dance but probably don't dance on the
job and and if you do which you
shouldn't but definitely don't record it
and put it online and then the other
possibility is that these dancing videos
are being done at hospitals where there
there isn't really anybody or hardly
anyone dying of the corona virus and if
that's the case and you've got so much
time on your hands then you know I think
that's gonna be very annoying to put a
mildly for all the people who have lost
their jobs because of supposedly
overwhelmed hospitals and then it turns
out that actually you've got all these
hospitals that are not only overwhelmed
are not only not overwhelmed but they're
but the hospital staff have so much time
on their hands that they're
choreographing dance routines I think
someone has lost their job or can't go
to work we'll look at that and say okay
well maybe I can get back to work then
in that case so that's the point this is
from Janis finally it says I'm glad you
you have nothing to do with public
health decisions you are a [ __ ] my
questions are were you born a crack baby
didn't you get enough the answer's no to
that by the way didn't you get enough
oxygen at birth not sure abused by an
uncle when you are a teenager no
something is seriously wrong with you
and then she quotes me quote if you
think the government has the right to
summarily declare all churches
non-essential and then arrest anyone who
tries to enter one you're entitled to
make that insanely stupid argument just
please I beg you never again pretend to
be a proponent of religious liberty yes
that is a quote I did say that and I'm
exactly right and then she continues
this isn't
about religious liberty you effing
nutjob these people are fake effing
Christians they are ok with harming
others so they can go to church if you
nutjobs had it your way we'd all be dead
f you and f your fake Christianity
churches are not essential churches and
religion are only essential
quote/unquote to people who cannot think
rashly and critically you all claim God
is everywhere why do you need to be in
an effing church you don't effing
religious liberty doesn't extend to
harming others you're the insanely
stupid one actually you even look
disturbed well Janice I all I could say
is I guess it would take one to know one
on that end but but thank you for that I
think I probably don't need to add
anything to that I really do appreciate
your perspective and you revealing all
of that to everybody and I want to thank
you for that I'm no response isn't
necessary I believe I appreciate the
feedback and we'll leave it there
everybody thanks everyone for watching
have a great day
Godspeed wait have a great day god bless
and Godspeed
I messed it up see you later
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson
the Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
defended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there